welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
and after one division people thought
i'd stop doing fan theory videos
but in the words of captain america no i
don't think i will now the first episode
of falcon in the wood to soldier has
just dropped and there's a lot to unpack
from it including who the new cap is
and what's going on with the flag
smashes full spoilers ahead so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out yet
then i highly recommend that you take
all the stupid with you for clicking
this video in the first place
probably not the best time to ask you to
like the video but if you enjoy it then
flag smash that thumbs up
and subscribe for breakdowns on the show
every week without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into it okay so episode one of
fatwoods
which is what i'm calling it now because
that's what disney abbreviated it to
that has a big reveal at the end of it
that shows the shield has been taken up
by a new captain america
after steve passed the mantle to sam the
character clearly wrestled with whether
he was worthy enough to carry the shield
or not
in the six months since the events of
endgame it seems like he's just had it
hid under his bed
like some dirty maxim magazines you had
when you were 14.
because we open on him getting ready to
take it to the smithsonian
and then cut to the mission before that
on the border of libya i think this
cements that sam hasn't taken the shield
out with him ever
now we also know that he's been working
alongside the air force for these six
months
and that's a long time for him to go
without picking it up
clearly this was a burden he didn't
really want as cap not only stands as a
hero
but he's also a symbol of america in sam
wilson captain america
which is the comic that the series is
based on sam to pay slip service to this
he states that he thought being captain
america would just be about punching
villains and attending parades
but it goes far beyond that in the
source material america is on the brink
of civil war
with the right and left at each other's
throats and sam realizes it's almost
impossible to walk the line in which
both will view him as their symbol of
the country though this hasn't been
brought up in the show yet
we can assume that it's aspects like
this that have some questioning whether
he's the right person or not
thus he gave the shield back but i don't
think that he ever believed he'd be
replaced so quickly
thus when the new captain america shows
up at the end
it feels like a kick in the balls now we
know from behind the scenes
info that this is john walker for them
to replace sam so quickly
i think that the government has had this
plan in place for a long time
and it's likely that they put him and
other people through rigorous testing
programs in order to select the right
person for the job
i'll get into how this could tie into
the flag smashes later on
but in the comics john walker started
off as the villain super patriot
walker's brother michael was killed
during the vietnam war
and jon grew up idolizing him in his
sacrifice
he joined the military and after
receiving training
slotted into the role super patriot
walker started to publicly discredit
captain america
stating that he didn't really represent
the ideals of the united states
and he began to stage attacks in order
to make it look like he
was the true savior i do believe that
this will tie over into the show as well
and throughout it that walker will help
the flag smashers to carry out attacks
so that he can show up and save the day
this will make him seem like
more of a hero and though this aesthetic
was present in mysterio 2
it does have basis in the source
material now similar to what we see in
the show
walker did become captain america at one
point
cap vacated the mantle and after jon
changed his views
he became the next in line to bear the
shield however he wasn't that well
received by
either the audience or the characters in
the comics themselves
throughout the decades there have been
several character switches like this
and the one that i always go back to is
asriel in the batman
nightfall lock he replaced bruce wayne
as the dark knight
and was disliked by many because of his
brutality
and general swanky attitude he thinks he
owns the place
you don't mate you're a [ __ ] now
this was murder and walker but these
character switches
do serve a purpose in showing everything
that could be bad about these heroes and
their mantles
they also showcase why steve and bruce
are so perfect for the roles
this is something that i think is also
present in sam's mind state too
in questioning whether he's even worthy
to be capped or not
he's showing that he is yeah he is
because he doesn't want to be so he is
steve was picked not because he was the
biggest or strongest
or even the fastest youtuber on the net
but rather because of the person that he
was on the inside
now stephen walker ended up having a
showdown and after this the latter lost
the name
because he was deemed unworthy he begged
his death and returned as the anti-hero
us
agent which is the persona that he's
carried since
wearing a variation of the captain
america costume and carrying a vibranium
disc as a shield
he continued to walk the line between
good and bad
one thing that has always remained
though is his respect for cap
now in sam wilson captain america walker
was actually ordered by cap to publicly
humiliate sam
and the two ended up fighting in the
street whilst the public watched on
this was put in place to make sam
looking worthy and i definitely think
that the bigger sam gets
the more likely it is that the two will
face off we've already seen from people
that sam has encountered
that they greatly admire all that he's
done and even though they're not
approving his loan application
he's viewed as a hero in the public eye
maybe they should leave him
alone hey get that noise
don't don't dislike the video yeah that
was an all right one now i think that
it'll come down to the pair going head
to head
after sam and bucky learn that walker is
helping the flag smashers to carry out
attacks
in the trailers we see the semi-truck
scene and walker is actually on it at
one point
therefore i think sam getting too close
to these attacks will make walker
realize that he has to take him out
before he uncovers the truth and that
will be a big driving force in the
series
now as for the flag smashers themselves
the one we saw operating in the episode
demonstrated superhuman strength
if walker is in line with his comic book
adaptation
then it means that he has this ability
too i think this ties in with the flag
smashes powers
walker likely wasn't picked overnight
and potentially
he has been experimenting or two with a
number of other candidates
in one division we saw as hayward was
trying to provide a line of defense for
the planet envision
and it could be possible that the
government were trying to recreate
captain america for the same reason
walker made it all the way to the finish
line but there are potentially a lot of
other people that ended up going
through the process that have been left
out in the wild in captain america civil
war we saw
a full training program for people who
too had the super soldier serum in them
and they were extremely dangerous
potentially the flag smashers were put
through this as well
and they had instilled in them the
ideals of america
however after being rejected and seeing
the pageantry of what it meant to be the
captain
they may have gone back on these notions
and turned to a life of attempting to
take down society
in the comics flag smasher was a villain
who believed that borders infringed on
freedom
and that governments on the whole
instilled hatred in their people by
pitting them against their neighbors
through making them believe that left
and right should be at war i think that
this will be the case here with walker
actually wanting to potentially
overthrow the government at large
so that things to stabilize like how
they were before the blip
this has been brought up as a motive for
their actions and potentially due to the
population being dwindled there were
actually more opportunities for the
survivors
i kind of feel that in the way walker is
seen as the hero at first
that he will eventually be revealed as a
villain juxtaposing this
i think that the flag shaggers sorry
flag smashers
might become somewhat sympathetic
figures potentially they've been used by
the government and then cast to the side
i think that this will create an
interesting political talking point
which
yeah the captain america series has
always done now obviously i'd love to
hear your thoughts and theories on
everything that we've discussed
so make sure you comment below and let
me know as a thank you for interacting
with the video you'll be entered into a
prize through on the 31st of march in
which we're giving away three copies of
a marvel 4k box set of your choice
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at heavy
spoilers
there's something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the first episode
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom and pointed out all the
easter eggs we could
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch without
the way thank you for sitting through
the video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
take care peace